you know um
there are such things as coincidences
there really are i've had coincidences
where
you know uh i'm on a flight and i happen
to be sitting next to alex jones lawyer
just after alex jones attacks me that is
a freaking predator right there okay
like that's a coincidence i don't
believe that there's any
larger message for me to glean from
being sat on a plane next to alex jones
lawyer it's just a coincidence but then
sometimes you start to see coincidence
after coincidence and it starts to
really not seem like a coincidence and
indeed it is now hard to believe that
there is anything short of a concerted
effort to cover up elements of the
january 6 trump riot planning and
communications and involvement of all
sorts of different parties in and around
the trump administration what am i
talking about well here's the latest
news
january 6 text messages
were wiped from phones
of key trump pentagon officials
it is starting to be very difficult to
believe that these are mere benign
coincidences
texts were deleted
they were transitioning to new devices
at exactly this time after being told
preserve the text messages the dod wiped
phones all of the same group of people
uh and of of uh
specifically at a time and related to
january 6. it's hard to believe in this
number of coincidences let's look at
what cnn reports the defense department
wiped the phones wiped and flushed guys
the phones of top departing dod and army
officials at the end of the trump
administration deleting any key texts
from key witnesses to events surrounding
the january 6th attack on the u.s
capitol
the acknowledgment that the phones from
the pentagon officials had been wiped
was first revealed in a foia lawsuit
american oversight brought against the
defense department and army
the watchdog group seeks january 6
records from former acting secretary of
defense chris miller former chief of
staff cash patel
former secretary of the army ryan
mccarthy and other prominent pentagon
officials
miller patel and mccarthy have all been
viewed as crucial witnesses for
understanding the government response to
the riots and former president trump's
reaction all three were involved in the
defense department's response to sending
national guard troops to the capitol as
the riot was unfolding there is no
suggestion that the officials themselves
erased the records
oh boy
oh boy
everyone involved who committed a crime
should be in jail or prison i'm not
saying
imprison people without due process and
without finding them guilty that's not
what i'm saying i'm saying they there
should be no
exempt exemptions here because of
people's roles whether it be in dod or
wherever the case may be
every day criminals
get in trouble all the time for
destroying evidence
white-collar criminals
often when it comes to tampering with or
destruction of evidence
end up in a situation where prosecutors
go ah it's really hard to prove that
they acted intentionally
gonna be very difficult to prove state
of mind here and yet we know it's not
that difficult because everyday
criminals street criminals as they are
sometimes called
get in trouble regularly for these exact
same things and there are just too many
coincidences here to believe that this
was not some kind of concerted effort
now you might recall
that days before what was ultimately the
final the last and final january 6th
committee hearing there was the idea
that on a beautiful tuesday the house
committee was going to get
recovered text messages from these
tranches of text messages that were
deleted
and
hours before the deadline
the revelation was
not recoverable not going to get them
sorry
and every aspect of this raises
questions as to in which organizations
were there
foot soldiers for lack of a better term
for the trump riot cover-up now we can't
say that secrets so part of this is
related to secret service here we're
talking about dod
i'm not ready to say
secret service was involved
but the longer it goes it starts to get
weird because on the one hand we have
secret service agents who supposedly
said in the aftermath of cassidy
hutchinson's devastating testimony about
what happened on january 6 we're willing
to come in and testify under oath about
all the lies cassidy hutchinson was
telling and i said at the time well
great get them under oath but then we'll
have competing under oath statements
until then all we have is nonsense and
then they never testified and the house
committee was welcoming them with open
arms and they never testified that
starts to get a little bit weird
then we hear well the text messages
involving the secret service also aren't
recoverable we can't give you anything
sorry
okay it starts to get a little weird now
we find out that the dod was wiping
phones
starting to get even weirder so i'm not
pretending to have an answer i'm not
positing any particular allegation of a
conspiracy i'm merely saying there's too
many coincidences here to believe that
this is merely a coincidence and there
seem to be actors in multiple
organizations at multiple agencies in
multiple levels of this
who don't seem to be forthcoming in the
way that you would imagine and that you
would hope government officials would be
that's where i will leave it and the
speculation can sort of go from there if
you have an idea as to what you believe
took place here find me on twitter at
deepakman and let me know who was
involved
and to what extent